il est 19 heures 14 avant de retrouver
vos éditions locales rencontre avec
philippe charpentier en artiste peintre
du sancerrois son univers c'est la
peinture abstraite une peinture
abstraite très coloré et sa très bonne
maîtrise du dessin et de la peinture lui
valent beaucoup de reconnaissance depuis
plus de trente ans aussi bien des
galleries des critiques d'art que des
amateurs
actuellement ces toiles sont visibles à
la galerie capazza de danse et c'est
dans le cher il avait le racing est allé
le voir dans son atelier le montage est
signé anna stridente
je me suis jamais dit elle veut devenir
peintre
je vais faire les tableaux où j'ai eu la
chance de démarrer ça démarre assez
rapidement va lâcher c'est une chance et
c'est que ma passion devait dire quelque
chose
c'est comme si la musique et des mémés
qui nous parlent et d'autres pas
car philippe charpentier et musiciens
aussi dans les années 70 il est batteur
dans des groupes de jazz et de rock
en 1981 il décide de se consacrer
entièrement à la peinture
il quitte alors paris s'installe dans le
sancerrois la nature ban inspiré ici
l'artiste peint comme une vie et vie
comme il peut
m
peinture je suis d
je suis débordée par l je suis dedans je
suis dedans et à l'extérieur en même
temps et en fait j'ai besoin d'être
partout de le changer
j'utilise beaucoup de techniques
différentes pour ok les interactions des
pour moi c'est l'énergie et ceux de
l'énergie pure
j'aime tout technique des études travail
et dans la famille c'est d'aquarelles du
dessin que j'ai démarré par la peinture
à l'huile le pastel
lavitola gravure somme c'est un tout
l'appareil la peinture il faut il faut
en avoir exploré toutes les techniques
pour finir par trouver un langage les
gestes et vif
ça fuse ça éclabousse de tous les côtés
il n'a pas de temps à perdre philippe
charpentier guidé par une sorte
d'urgence intérieur les couleurs
jaillissent aussi elle s'accroche à la
toile au rythme de ses émotions et de
son humeur le résultat est à son image
généreux et passionné